economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela buena
noche bienvenida el regulador
estadounidense intervino una batalla
entre grandes y pequeños inversionistas
de wall suites así es de raúl muy buenas
noches pues recordemos primero que esta
pelea gira en torno a un foro en la red
social ruedita a través del cual
pequeños inversionistas se lanzaron en
masa a comprar acciones de una empresa
llamada game stop esto disparó su acción
e hizo que los grandes fondos de la
bolsa de nueva york perdieron miles de
millones de dólares la comisión de
valores de eeuu anunció hoy que revisará
de cerca las acciones tomadas por las
entidades reguladas que pueden
perjudicar a los inversores o inhibir
indebidamente su capacidad para negociar
con ciertos valores y es que después de
lo sucedido algunas aplicaciones de
corretaje sin comisiones que son las que
usan estos pequeños inversionistas
vetaron el jueves la compra de acciones
de gamestop y se llevaron todas las
críticas y hasta una demanda colectiva
ellos es que dejan de porque los grandes
si pueden comprar y vender libremente
y cuando son los pequeños los que están
ganando ahí sí se suspenden las
transacciones vamos a ver qué pasa
entonces en esta disputa daniela y este
viernes entró en vigencia el impuesto a
la riqueza en argentina raúl este es un
gravamen que será cobrado por una sola
vez a quienes posean grandes fortunas
para recaudar unos 3.400 millones de
dólares para hacerle frente a la
pandemia hoy fue expedida la
reglamentación que dice que están
sujetas 11 mil 855 personas a este
impuesto se trata de un pago único de
entre un 2 y un 3.5 por ciento del
patrimonio de quienes tengan una riqueza
de más de 200 millones de pesos
argentinos esto es un poco más de dos
millones de dólares o diez mil si se
pone en términos de salarios mínimos
mensuales en este país
daniela y siguen conociéndose resultados
del pib de 220 el año pasado vamos con
mexico primero el dato preliminar
refleja una contracción del 8,5 por
ciento
este es un mayor descenso desde la gran
depresión de los años 30 cuando llegó a
caer más
y también sigue una tendencia que ya
venía desde antes de la pandemia cuando
el pib cayó 0 1 % entre tanto también se
conoció que la economía española se
desplomó en un 11% el año pasado está
eso en su contracción más alta desde la
guerra civil de hace casi 90 años y
también terminó con 6 años de
crecimiento danielle hablando de riqueza
y de dinero le quiero preguntar cuánto
vale una mención de twitter del hombre
más rico del mundo mira esa historia tan
maravillosa raúl el excéntrico hilo en
moscú quien es el dueño de la marca de
autos de lujo tesla ha demostrado ser
una verdadera máquina de dinero sonó
recientemente superó a jeff pesos como
el hombre más rico del mundo ahora bastó
con que pusieran su perfil de twitter
una etiqueta con la palabra bitcoin para
que el precio de la que tú moneda más
usada del mundo se disparara en 14 por
ciento la kripta divisa llegó a ganar
hasta cuatro mil dólares en una sola
sesión y cerró sobre los 37 mil esto es
apenas el último de una serie de
movimientos de mercado provocados por
comentarios de hilo
en sus redes sociales le tengo tres
ejemplos raúl mire el martes tuiteó
gamestop en referencia a lo que estaba
sucediendo con gamestop después las
acciones de un desarrollador de juegos
polacos se dispararon en 16 por ciento
cuando el tuiteo que podría jugar
cyberpunk que es uno de sus juegos y
después de escribir que como que le
estaba gustando mucho xxi y que le había
comprado objetos a su perro allí la
plataforma de venta minorista en línea
avanzó un 9 por ciento en bolsa no en
vano sus seguidores en el foro de
acciones de redit se refieren a él como
papá más que cariñosamente me fuera
menos haría el indicador es el ejército
de inversores minoristas desencadenó la
peor semana de wall street desde octubre
y tiene los grandes fondos al borde de
un ataque de nervios' en europa están
también pendientes del retraso en el
envío de vacunas y puso a los mercados a
generar pérdidas y muy malos resultados
también en las bolsas de américa latina
cifra el día para finalizar otra
interesante 54 mil dólares en ese valor
se subastó en hong kong una botella de
whisky de
32 años de la marca lengrand de escocia
a pesar de la incertidumbre económica
provocada por la pandemia el interés por
los whiskies raros y coleccionables
sigue siendo muy alto raúl le interesa o
no claro que me interesa daniela más hoy
viernes muchísimas gracias fueron a la
información económica ustedes también
gracias continué con nosotros y buena
noche
[Música]